I'm alone, be I won't be soon In New York City, when I see you.
我独自一人，但很快我就不会了，在纽约市，当我见到你。
Please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
请允许我在纽约市把一切都告诉你。
Hello, hello and welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother.
你好，你好，欢迎收听又一期的《我们是如何创造你母亲的》。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I'm here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Josh!
乔什！
Hey, Craig!
嘿，克雷格！
I don't know.
我不知道。
I want to try something else.
我想尝试点别的。
Just your name.
只说你的名字。
Josh, you know, you fall into a rut, you go, I'm here as ever with my friend, you're just like, damn, this is the same thing every time.
乔什，你知道，你陷入了一种陈规，你会说，就像以往一样，我和我的朋友在这里，然后你就会觉得，该死，每次都一样。
So I'm glad I'm glad we mixed it up.
所以我很高兴我们换了种方式。
Yeah, we're mixed.
对，我们换了方式。
This is great.
这太棒了。
Well, this is a great episode to mix it up with because this is all, this is a, we were talking about columns two episodes ago, which was a little more straightforward linear.
嗯，这是一个很适合换换方式的剧集，因为这整集，这是一个，我们在两集前讨论过专栏，那一集更直白、更线性。
And this is like, we're talking about Lucky Penny today.
而这一集，我们今天在聊《幸运硬分币》。
This is a podcast, by the way, we talk about how I met your mother, which is a TV show that I start in skyped over as Ted Mosby and and Craig co-created the show with his buddy and my buddy Carter Baze and we're making our way through, we're deep into episode, sorry season two.
顺便说一下，这是一个播客，我们讨论的是《老爸老妈浪漫史》，这是一部电视剧，我在里面扮演泰德·莫斯比，而克雷格和他的好朋友、我的好朋友卡特·贝斯共同创作了这部剧，我们正在重温，已经深入到剧集的，抱歉，第二季了。
This is an episode called Lucky Penny, which is a great episode, really funny.
这一集叫《幸运硬分币》，这是一集非常棒、非常搞笑的剧集。
I feel like a lot of the virtues and kind of bravura storytelling strokes of that, how I made your mother's best at or really on display here.
我觉得《老爸老妈浪漫史》最擅长的许多优点和那种高超的叙事手法在这集里得到了真正的展现。
Yeah, I will give Carter a ton of credit.
是的，我要给卡特记上一大功。
This is very much a Carter Bayes, the brilliant Carter Bayes, a baby of his, just the shape of going backwards in time to find out where it all started.
这很大程度上是卡特·贝斯，才华横溢的卡特·贝斯的心血结晶，仅仅是那种倒叙回去寻找这一切是如何开始的结构。
It's kind of the whole series in miniatures in this episode.
这一集某种程度上就是整个剧集的微缩版。
I love episodes like this where the whole episode, it's like the mosquito in amber containing the dinosaur DNA or there's just, the whole show is in episodes like this and it's a mystery, whose fault is it Ted is in this situation.
我喜欢这样的剧集，整集就像是琥珀里包裹着恐龙DNA的蚊子，或者说，整部剧的精髓就在这样的剧集里，而且这是一个谜，泰德陷入这种境地到底是谁的错。
How far back can you trace it?
你能追溯到多久以前？
It's another mini mystery within the larger mystery of the series.
这是剧集宏大谜团中的另一个迷你谜团。
I really like that about this.
我真的很喜欢这一点。
It is a good episode.
这确实是一集好剧。
And also another encoded thing is, I believe, Ted's daughter is named Penny.
还有另一个埋藏的伏笔是，我记得，泰德的女儿叫佩妮。
Isn't that right?
不是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Which we didn't know at the time we did this.
我们拍这集的时候并不知道这一点。
We added that later.
我们是后来才加上去的。
This is the seed planted that will grow into that.
这就是种下的种子，日后会成长为那样。
Yeah.
是的。
And just another, I know, you know, Ted Mosby, I often say, well, he's not real, but let's just call him real.
还有另外一点，我知道，你知道，泰德·莫斯比，我经常说，虽然他不是真人，但我们就当他是真人吧。
Let's call him some sort of archetype avatar that's floating out there in the cosmos.
我们就把他当成某种在宇宙中飘荡的原型化身吧。
And I just want to say, Ted, I'm so sorry they discontinued the pennies, the US mints.
我只想说，泰德，我很遗憾美国铸币局停产了硬分币。
I'm sure this was a hard day for him.
我确信这对他是艰难的一天。
I let it pass without much commemoration personally, but I know that Ted probably felt the sting of that.
我个人没有进行太多纪念就让它过去了，但我知道泰德可能感受到了那种刺痛。
I forget if we were recording or we talked about this separately.
我忘了我们是在录音时还是私下讨论过这个。
When did we say this on the pod already?
我们在播客里说过这个吗？
Once we did, we did, but it's very, it's very much.
我们说过，我们说过，但这真的很有意义。
It's worth really, it really moves me the idea that you thought of that because I saw that new story and sort of didn't think twice.
你想到这一点真的让我很感动，因为我看到那个新闻报道时根本没多想。
But you as the guy that brought Ted to life in your body, you were Ted.
但你作为把泰德带到现实中并赋予其生命的人，你就是泰德。
You inhabited that character.
你融入了那个角色。
You, you felt, you felt it emotionally.
你感同身受，在情感上感受到了。
You felt it in the cosmos that Ted, wherever he exists.
你在宇宙中感受到了泰德无论他在哪里。
Now it is, he's not happy.
现在他很不高兴。
He's just sad about it, he lit a candle for the dearly departed U.S. penny.
他只是为此感到难过，他为不幸离世的美分硬币点了一根蜡烛。
Yeah, he did.
是的，他确实点。
He definitely lit a candle.
他绝对点了一根蜡烛。
Actually, from the Facebook group from Mahalah, she asks, do you ever think about the fact that Lucky Penny kind of sounds like Luke and Penny?
事实上，来自玛哈拉的Facebook粉丝提问说，你有没有想过“幸运硬分币”（Lucky Penny）听起来有点像“卢克和佩妮”（Luke and Penny）？
Oh, boy.
噢，天哪。
Great observation.
绝佳的观察。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
Yeah, that's a great observation, Luke and Penny.
对，这是一个绝佳的观察，卢克和佩妮。
I mean, yeah, we didn't know it yet, but the seeds are planted here.
我的意思是，是的，我们当时并不知道，但种子就是在这里种下的。
Yeah, for sure.
是的，肯定的。
That's awesome.
太棒了。
That's great.
Alec, tell us when when did this episode air?
亚历克，告诉我们这一集是什么时候播出的？
Originally, February 12th, 2007, written by, I want to say Jamie Ronheimer.
最初是2007年2月12日，编剧，我想是杰米·罗恩海默。
I think so.
我想是的。
Can you look it up to Delver?
你能查一下确认一下吗？
Yeah, I want to say lots of things, Alec.
亚历克，我想说很多事情。
I don't just say them.
我可不是随便说说的。
Yeah, wait, it's right in front of me here.
等等，它就在我面前。
Here it is.
在这呢。
No, I don't know.
不，我不知道。
Yes, Jamie, Jamie Ronheimer, very funny dude, wrote this one, I, yeah, this is a great one.
是的，杰米，杰米·罗恩海默，一个非常搞笑的家伙，写了这一集，我，是的，这一集真的很棒。
By the way, Penny, but now when we see an episode about a penny, we can say old tech.
顺便说一句，佩妮，但现在当我们看到一集关于硬分币的剧时，我们可以说这是老科技了。
Yeah, exactly.
对，没错。
Well, speaking of, there is an old tech thing that becomes like an updated tech when they're tracking the marathon, tracking the marathon, which of course is find your friends, which is like, yeah, Rebecca was like, ooh, that's old.
说到这个，有一个老科技的东西在他们追踪马拉松时变成了一种更新的科技，追踪马拉松当然就是Find Your Friends（查找我的朋友），当时丽贝卡就觉得，哦，这太老了。
That's outdated.
这过时了。
That would just be your phone now.
现在这直接就是你的手机了。
Yeah, but there's also, but Barney making a phone call from the train, which at the time, there is no chance you could have done, but now totally could do.
对，但还有，巴尼在火车上打电话，当年这绝对是不可能的，但现在完全可以做到。
Yeah.
是的。
Wait, that wasn't on train, but like at the stop to the station, you couldn't get a signal back then?
等等，那不是在火车上，而是在车站的站台，那时候你连不上信号吗？
Maybe.
也许吧。
I'm going to say it's a maybe.
我只能说有可能。
I don't think it was a definite.
我觉得不是绝对的。
Well, this is like, this is literally, this is actually a very, an amazing inflection point because I think 2007 when this episode aired was the release of the iPhone, right?
嗯，这简直是，这实际上是一个非常惊人的转折点，因为我认为2007年这集播出时正是iPhone发布的时候，对吧？
are correct.
完全正确。
2007, like, you know, Jonathan Hight and all these people are marking that as a perilous and momentous kind of turn in human history.
2007年，就像乔纳森·海特和其他所有人所说的那样，这标志着人类历史上危险而重大的转折。
Yeah, the end of a certain era.
对，一个特定时代的结束。
Yeah, like we were on the air.
是的，就像我们当时正在播出一样。
And, you know, I think we've talked about this, but like I might have had a flip phone when I got to how I met your mother, and then the trio, we all had trios.
而且，你知道，我想我们讨论过这个，但当我加入《老爸老妈浪漫史》时我可能用的是翻盖手机，后来我们三个人，我们都换了Treo手机。
The trio, we all got the trio.
Treo，我们都买了Treo。
With the little pen stick, the little stick.
带着那种小笔，那个小棍子。
Oh yeah, that's right, the little stylist.
哦对，没错，那个小触控笔。
thing?
那个东西？
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
The stylist, the stick.
触控笔，那个小棍。
I was the last person to get an iPhone and I remember Dave Baker kind of helping me with it and kind of like, it was a little bit like you're going under.
我是最后一个买iPhone的人，我记得戴夫·贝克帮我弄过它，那种感觉有点像，你快要沉沦了。
Like you're about to go under and be some zoom.
就像你快要沉沦然后变成某种低头族一样。
It's a matrix moment.
这是一个黑客帝国时刻。
It's like, yeah.
就像是，是的。
It's a moment I took very casually that I look back on now and think, huh, that really ruined my life.
那是我当时觉得无所谓、现在回想起来却觉得“哈，那真的毁了我一生”的一个瞬间。
I wish I could go back with some more guardrails.
我真希望能带着更多防范措施回到过去。
But anyway, yeah, that that made me laugh, old tech, tracking, tracking thing.
不过总之，对，那个让我笑了，老梗，追踪，追踪那事。
Yeah.
对。
There was also another old ref, which I like, are we sticking with old ref?
还有一个老梗我也挺喜欢，我们要坚持用老梗吗？
Let's stick with old ref.
咱们就用老梗吧。
I think where you were, it's our twist on the office lady's old tech.
我觉得你刚才提的那个，是我们对职场女性老梗的魔改。
Yeah, let's commit.
对，那就这么定了。
Let's commit.
就这么定了。
What was it like he tried to bet me that it hungry like the wolf was sung by men at work?
什么来着，他试图跟我打赌说《Hungry Like the Wolf》是“Men at Work”乐队唱的？
And then he tried to get them to record it.
然后他还想让他们去录这首歌。
He tried to record it.
他试图录制它。
Yeah, that one, you'd have to look up if you're under about 45 or so, right?
对，那个梗，如果你大概45岁以下的话，你还得去查一下，对吧？
You'd have to the kids today.
现在的孩子们得去查。
But if you were a kid, when we were kids, 100%, that's like a classic hardy musical reference.
但如果你在我们小的时候是个孩子，百分之百，那就像是个经典的死硬派音乐梗。
You know, both bands, you know, multiple hits by both bands.
你知道，两个乐队，你知道，两个乐队都有好几首热门歌曲。
You can remember the videos of each of them on MTV.
你还能记起他们在MTV上的各个音乐录影带。
Yeah.
对。
Look, we have some of those.
听着，我们确实有一些那样的梗。
It can't all be timeless, folks.
不可能全都是永恒经典的，各位。
It can't all be timeless.
不可能全都是永恒经典的。
We were off our moment.
我们当时有点不在状态。
Yeah.
对。
So Craig, just take us through a little bit of what this episode is and where it came from.
所以克雷格，给我们简单讲讲这一集是关于什么的，以及它的灵感来源。
Like where did the spring from, the writer's room?
比如说，这个创意是从哪里冒出来的，编剧室吗？
Yeah, I mean, I think we wanted to tell a story in reverse, the way that the series is kind of in reverse in certain ways, or at least a big go back from the year 2030.
对，我是觉得，我们想用倒叙的方式讲一个故事，这种方式在某种程度上契合了整部剧的倒叙风格，或者说至少是从2030年回溯的一次重大倒叙。
And that idea that when something goes wrong in your life, you try to be this forensic detective and go, how, what do I trace this back to?
还有那种想法：当你的生活出了问题时，你会试图当一个法医侦探，去想：怎么回事？我该把这追溯到哪一步？
What can I blame this on?
我能把这怪到谁头上？
And it's a series of Ted thinking, Ted and Robin, thinking they've found the reason there in this terrible situation of Ted being about to miss a flight to a huge potential career opportunity in Chicago.
这就串联起了一系列泰德的想法，泰德和罗宾认为他们找到了导致这一糟糕处境的原因——泰德差点错去芝加哥争取一个极具潜力的职业发展机会的航班。
Um, and the idea that you're sitting there pretending you had control over life.
呃，还有那种你坐在那儿，假装自己能掌控生活的感觉。
And you're trying to, you're trying to do the detective work of like, this is where it all happened.
然后你试图去做侦探工作，觉得：这一切就是从这里开始的。
This is why it happened.
这就是原因所在。
And I think that's a very Ted Mosby way of thinking that's part of why it's a great episode.
我觉得这非常符合泰德·莫斯比的思维方式，这也是这一集为什么这么棒的一部分原因。
And it is a very fun storytelling structure to just go backwards, backwards, backwards, backwards and see how all of those little stories overlap and connect and one informs the other.
而且这是一个非常有趣的叙事结构，就是一直往回、往回、往回、往回走，看所有这些小故事是如何重叠、相连，并且一个启发另一个的。
And in the end Ted realizes he goes so far back in this attempt that he realizes he himself is he kicked off the whole chain of events, so.
最后泰德意识到，在这次尝试中他回溯得太远了，以至于他发现自己才是那个引发了整个事件链的人，所以……
Right.
对。
Well, again, that's the kind of encapsulation nutshell meta kind of stroke in this episode, which is, I mean, I've done this with many things in my life.
没错，这正是这一集中那种浓缩的、高度概括的、带有元叙事色彩的东西，我的意思是，我在生活中的很多事情上也这样做过。
Like if I hadn't met this person, they brought me here and I met so-and-so, I've done that with how I met my wife and all this stuff.
比如，如果我没有遇到这个人，他们就不会把我带到这儿，我也就不会遇到某某某，我和我妻子是怎么认识的我也这么干过，诸如此类。
But like, if you really get granular and cosmic about it, you're like, well, it started with the Big Bang.
但如果你把这推演得极其细致、宏大，你会觉得：好吧，这一切始于宇宙大爆炸。
Like, it all started with the Big Bang.
就像，这一切都始于宇宙大爆炸。
And maybe before, what caused the Big Bang, who knows?
也许在那之前呢，是什么引发了宇宙大爆炸，谁知道呢？
There's no end to that game.
这种游戏是永远玩不完的。
That's also, that was Ted.
这也是，那正是泰德。
That was Ted.
那正是泰德。
Yeah, he's the reason we all exist, yeah.
对，他就是我们所有人存在的原因，对。
Before it was darkness, and then Ted had media.
在此之前是一片黑暗，然后泰德有了媒体。
Talk about an architect.
真不愧是个建筑师。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, I mean, it's a fun kind of sliding doors game to play.
对，我是说，这是一种很有趣的“滑动门”式游戏。
Because it's true, like, you know, you're lying.
因为这是真的，比如，你知道，你在撒谎。
They're literally sliding doors in the episode.
这一集里字面意思上就有滑动门。
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
对，对，确实。
But your life changes in what seemingly casual moments reveal themselves to be very consequential.
但你的生活却在那些看似随意的时刻发生了改变，而这些时刻后来证明至关重要。
Yeah.
对。
And the ending of this episode is very pointed and I know here we are telling the episode backwards starting at the end, but I really like that it fits the form.
这一集的结尾非常直白，我知道我们现在是从结尾开始倒着聊这一集，但我真的很喜欢这种形式。
I really like the future narrator having the last word in this episode of you can do all All the detective work you want, 2007, Ted, but I, 2030, Ted, know that it was a great thing that you missed that flight because if you had you taken that flight, you might live in Chicago, you wouldn't be telling the story to those two kids because you wouldn't have met the mother.
我真的很喜欢未来旁白在这集中有最后发言权：不管你怎么做侦探工作，2007年的泰德，但我——2030年的泰德——知道你错过那个航班是一件大好事，因为如果你坐了那架航班，你可能就住在芝加哥了，你也就不会给那两个孩子讲这个故事了，因为你根本不会遇到他们的母亲。
You wouldn't have those kids.
你也不会有那些孩子。
That's a very cool, again, a Carta Bay is like very cool, big idea, big philosophical idea there.
这真的是一个，再次说明，卡特·贝斯（Carter Bays）的想法非常酷，宏大的想法，非常有哲理的想法。
And it's an, it's only an idea that a person who has enough sample size of life can put forward.
而且，这只有当一个人拥有足够的人生阅历时才能提出来。
Yeah, like you I don't remember in high school going well if this hadn't happened that wouldn't have happened like I wasn't thinking And I didn't have enough life to see the kind of pattern that you know when people like I mean, I think there's something about there's a there's a big Peptalk at the center and the heart of how I met your mother which is it's all working out in some fascinating way and it's on the universes on your side and your struggles are your teachers and you are being led somewhere by a benevolent hand and when it looks darkest you're you know what I mean like there's they're they're they're quite spiritually sound lessons at the heart of it that's why people keep watching it.
对，就像你——我不记得在高中时会想“要是当时没发生这事，就不会发生那事”——我当时根本不会这么想，也没有足够的人生经历去看清那种模式，你知道的，当人们……我的意思是，我觉得“老爸老妈浪漫史”的核心和精神深处有一种巨大的励志鸡汤，那就是：一切都在以某种迷人（fascinating）的方式顺利进行，宇宙是站在你这边的，你的挣扎就是你的导师，你正被一只仁慈的手引导去某处，当看起来最黑暗的时候，你懂我的意思吗——这就好比，它核心深处藏着非常具有精神启示意义的教训，这就是为什么人们一直在看。
And I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City will be right back.
我为你写了这首小曲，要在纽约市唱给你听，我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目中。
This detective work of who got us here.
关于“是谁把我们带到这里”的侦探工作。
We start in the present and we go backwards and backwards and backwards and backwards.
我们从现在开始，然后不断地往回、往回、往回、再往回。
It is a thinking man's episode.
这是一集需要动脑子的剧集。
It is a real thinker.
它真的是一部烧脑之作。
And I was excited watching it.
我看着的时候觉得很兴奋。
I was excited every time they were Ted and Robin in the then present in the 2007 present, realize, wait, no, the story goes back further.
每当看到身处当时的2007年现时的泰德和罗宾意识到“等等，不对，故事还要往前追溯”时，我都感到兴奋不已。
I was so on edge of my seat to see that next installment.
我当时简直紧张得坐立难安，急切地想看到接下来的情节。
It's such a great structure because it's like, wait, they're gonna back it up even further.
这个结构太棒了，因为就像是：等等，他们还要把时间再往前推。
What happened?
到底发生了什么？
Who really caused this problem?
究竟是谁真正导致了这个问题？
And it also allows everyone to be in the A story.
而且这也让每个人都能参与到主线故事中。
The whole gang is in the A story.
整个帮派都在主线故事里。
That's it.
就是这样。
It is interesting you drew comparison to columns, which is again, two episodes prior to this.
有趣的是，你把它和《专栏》作了对比，那也是在此之前的两集。
We were talking about how that was like A story, B story.
我们之前还在讨论那一集就像主线故事、副线故事那样。
They didn't connect that much.
它们并没有太多的联系。
And we had a really fucking hard time with that one.
我们当时拍那一集可真是他妈的太难了。
We just couldn't get it to quite sing in the way they wanted to.
我们就是没办法让它像预期那样出彩。
When you have an episode like that, it just has to have a lot of funny shit in it.
当你拍这样一集时，里面必须得有很多搞笑的烂梗。
And kids, it's hard to write funny shit.
孩子们，写好笑的烂梗可真难。
You're way better off.
你们最好还是……
You're way better off if you have a story structure that is like suspenseful and you have a series of reveals and twists and turns like that is much more our strength as one has it.
如果你有一个充满悬念、有一系列反转和波折的故事结构，那你会好过得多——这更符合我们的强项，或者说其中之一。
There's like an episode like columns or was cock-a-mouse in the matchmaker episode?
就像有一集叫《专栏》，或者《找猫记》还是《红娘》那一集？
Was that the same episode?
是同一集吗？
Yeah.
对。
So there's certain B stories that I feel like, and I don't mean this as a criticism of the Ryerusum.
所以有些副线故事我觉得——我这并不是在批评编剧室。
I can see them on the dry erase board.
我能想象出它们写在白板上的样子。
That's funny ideas that you're like, well, I guess I could go there.
那是些有趣的创意，你会想：好吧，也许我可以往这方面发展。
That could be the B story.
那可以作为副线故事。
And you almost swap it, you just drop it in.
你几乎可以把它们对调，直接塞进去。
And that's a lot of other sitcoms do it that way.
很多其他的情景喜剧都是这么做的。
It's like, these things can go together, there's no harm in combining them.
就像是：这些东西可以凑合在一起，把它们结合起来也没什么坏处。
But I think we are at our best when they have to go together.
但我认为，只有当它们“必须”结合在一起时，我们才是最棒的。
This episode, Lucky Penny is like a jenga.
这一集《幸运便士》就像是叠叠乐（jenga）。
It is.
确实如此。
Nothing can be removed.
什么都不能抽掉。
It's all perfectly placed there.
它们都完美地放在那里。
And I think that's very satisfying narratively to walk.
我觉得从叙事角度来看，这样推进非常令人满足。
It's very satisfying.
真的很令人满足。
And when you see one story walk into the end of one story, catch back up to the beginning of another.
当你看到一个故事延伸到另一个故事的结尾，然后又追溯回另一个故事的开头。
Like when Ted and Robin walk in eating those hot dogs that the pennies dollar 50 value about, and they walk into the wedding, you know, into Lily and Robin, you know, Lily, No, they walk into realizing there's a wedding dress sale, which of course kicks off eventually, Lily doing that.
就像当泰德和罗宾走进来，吃着佩妮价值1.50美元的热狗，然后他们走进婚礼现场，你知道的，走进莉莉和罗宾的，你知道的，莉莉，不对，他们走进去发现有一场婚纱大甩卖，当然这最终引发了莉莉去做那件事。
We have to stay up all night.
我们得熬夜。
I love how those fit together.
我喜欢它们结合在一起的方式。
I love it.
我太喜欢了。
I also love episodes.
我也很喜欢那些剧集。
These are a lot of the mystery episodes start this way.
很多悬疑剧集都是这样开始的。
They start with running panic, like brunch started, kind of like just weird and like almost with like an act of violence, like the, the traiping of the episode, the one that starred Alec Lev, but running.
它们以奔跑和恐慌开始，就像早午餐开始那样，有点奇怪，几乎带有一种暴力行为，就像那集一样，由亚历克·莱夫主演的那集，一直在奔跑。
That's the thing.
就是这样。
What?
什么？
when they were running.
当他们奔跑的时候。
Alex just woke up again.
亚历克又醒了。
Didn't it start with Lily and Marshall running racing?
不是从莉莉和马歇尔跑步比赛开始的吗？
Yeah.
对。
You know, there's something, Alec running and race.
你知道的，有些事，亚历克在跑步和比赛。
And Alec and his beloved fiance running, but there's something about those episodes that start with that high energy.
亚历克和他挚爱的未婚夫在奔跑，但有些剧集就是以那种高能量开始的。
And it also, I don't know, it's like a movie that opens at a car chase.
而且，我也说不上来，就像一部以汽车追逐开场的电影。
It was like, what is going on?
当时的感觉是，到底怎么回事？
You're immediately gripped.
你一下子就被吸引住了。
In media rests, right?
直接切入正题，对吧？
That's the first, that's the old school storytelling going back to the grease.
那是第一种，可以追溯到古希腊的老派叙事方式。
But like, yeah, Josh, you know what I'm thinking about when you say that too in this one, you do a lot of stunt work in this episode.
不过，是的，乔什，你知道当你说到这个时我在想什么吗，这一集里你做了很多特技动作。
You take a big fall at one point.
你在某个时刻摔得不轻。
I get tackled by the police.
我被警察扑倒了。
You get tackled by the police.
你被警察扑倒了。
You jump a turnstell, get tackled by the police.
你跳过旋转闸门，被警察扑倒。
It is, there is a lot, you were like an action star in this one.
确实有很多，你在这集里就像个动作明星。
The whole episode begins with you running.
整集一开始你就在奔跑。
I can't remember if I had a stunt.
我不记得我有没有做特技。
I think there was a stunt person.
我觉得当时有特技替身。
I can't remember if I did my own stunts or not.
我不记得自己有没有亲自上阵做特技了。
I mean, I was the Tom Cruise of the set.
我的意思是，我就是片场的汤姆·克鲁斯。
I've mostly waved off the stunt, man, I believe.
我记得我大部分时间都拒绝了特技替身。
I think you did because we're on you.
我想你确实自己上了，因为镜头对着你。
We see your face in those stunts and you were really physical and really like, it was great.
我们在那些特技镜头里看到了你的脸，你真的很卖力，而且真的，感觉太棒了。
I thought that was a very action role for Ted, this one.
我觉得对泰德来说，这算是一个很有动作戏的角色。
I do remember even in reading the draft, Barney has a couple of sex jokes, but the Barney story that he thinks you don't need to train for a marathon, you just run it, is so funny.
我甚至记得在读剧本初稿时，巴尼有一些色情笑话，但巴尼认为你不需要为马拉松进行训练、直接去跑就行的那个情节，实在是太搞笑了。
Okay, so that is a true story Carter either knows the person that did it or heard about it.
好吧，那是一个真实的故事，卡特要么认识这么个人，要么听说过这事。
I haven't heard back, I was trying to remember if it was someone he knew where he was once removed, but this really happened.
我还没得到回复，我一直在努力回想那是他认识的人，还是通过别人间接听说的，但这件事真的发生过。
Somebody was at a bar drinking and said, I could run that marathon tomorrow and did it.
有人在酒吧喝酒，然后说：“我明天就能跑完那场马拉松，”然后他真的去跑了。
And it was rendered basically, did it, like basically this story.
基本上就是这样实现的，就像这个故事一样。
I can't remember if it ended with that the person like actually being stuck in some way, but I think basically was like unable to walk the next day.
我不记得结局是不是那个人最后以某种方式动弹不得了，但我觉得基本上就是第二天连路都走不动了。
It was literally, it was physically incapacitated from having done it.
简直是字面意义上的身体残疾，因为跑了那场步。
And it's just one of those stories that Carter heard that he was just probably in the back of his head, like that's gold, that's gotta go somewhere.
这就是卡特听过的那类故事，可能在他的脑海深处觉得，这太棒了，必须得用在某个地方。
And that's the interesting thing about breaking an episode like this.
这就是拆解这样一集剧集的有趣之处。
You come up with the structure and you say, what's a funny vignette?
你构思出结构，然后问，什么样的小片段才好笑？
That can, we know exactly the size and shape.
我们能精准掌握它的规模和形状。
It has to be, it has to be this funny little story that can fit exactly right here.
它必须是这样一个有趣的小故事，能够严丝合缝地塞进这个位置。
And somehow it has to drag head into it and make Ted get arrested.
而且不知何故，它还得把泰德也拖下水，让泰德被捕。
How do we achieve that?
我们该怎么实现这一点？
And this was the perfect, the absolute perfect answer to that question.
而这就是对那个问题最完美的、绝对完美的答案。
Neil's Pratt fall when he thinks he can stand up and falls instead of standing on that subway.
尼尔在那个地铁车厢里，以为自己能站起来却反而摔倒时的那个精彩前扑。
Every time I will see that, I have to rewind it and watch it like three more times because he just so believes he's gonna stand up.
每次我看到那个画面，都得倒带再看个三遍，因为他真的深信自己能站起来。
Well, the way my memory of it, because I was watching the actual, I was watching, I was there that day, right?
嗯，根据我的记忆，因为我在看实际的，我在看，我那天就在现场，对吧？
So I'm watching him do it.
所以我看着他演。
And I remember thinking, this is unbelievably good physical comedy.
我记得当时心想：这是好得令人难以置信的肢体喜剧。
Oh my God, but it's such a, it's such a like, the given circumstances, like he ran a marathon with great hubris, he thinks it's already on, he has lost control of his leg.
天哪，但这是一个，这是一个，既定情境是：他盲目自大地跑了一场马拉松，他以为自己还能行，但他的腿已经失去控制了。
It's such a, it's such a, it's such a, it's such a hubris story.
这是一个，这是一个，这是一个关于狂妄自大的故事。
It's like a Greek myth.
就像希腊神话一样。
Like it's on, and a marathon, of course, comes from ancient Greece.
就像，开始了，而马拉松当然源自古希腊。
Yeah, yeah, but that's really funny.
对，对，但真的很好笑。
But that is really funny.
不过那是真的很好笑。
Yeah, but I remember the way it was shot was like, you saw it through the subway window, and you saw him just go down.
是的，但我记得拍摄的方式是，你是通过地铁车窗看到这一幕的，你看到他直接倒了下去。
But I saw him through the door, so I saw his whole body.
但我当时透过车门看他，所以我看到了他的整个身体。
And it was even more impressive live than it looks on that.
现场看比在成片里看起来还要震撼。
Like, him, he just like, I don't know, I just believed he didn't have use of his legs.
就好像他，我不知道，我真的相信他的双腿已经完全不听使唤了。
A ton of, just down like a ton of bricks.
整个人就像一堆砖头一样轰然倒地。
It's how casual his face is.
他的表情显得多么漫不经心啊。
His face doesn't know that fall is gonna happen.
他的脸根本不知道接下来会摔那么惨。
It's just a genius physical form.
这简直是天才般的肢体表现。
Yes, his body is split in two.
是的，他的身体从中间裂开了。
his upper body is feeling one thing, and his lower body is not cooperating.
他的上半身在感受着一回事，而他的下半身完全不配合。
It's so fucking funny.
真是他妈的太搞笑了。
Neil Patrick Harris, ladies and gentlemen, my God, he is just a genius there.
女士们先生们，尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯，天哪，他在那里简直是个天才。
He's such a good physical comedian.
他真是一个出色的肢体喜剧演员。
I loved when he said, I've seen where it turns around Ted, you don't ever want to see where the subway turns around.
我特别喜欢他说：“我知道地铁在哪里调头，泰德，你可千万不想看到地铁是在哪里调头的。”
Because the subway, if you live in New York City, by the way, we were watching it, he said, 86 on the four and five, I think, right?
因为如果你住在纽约市的话——顺便说一句，我们在看的时候，他说的是4号线和5号线的86街站，对吧？
Right, like that was her hometown spot.
没错，就像那是她的老家一样。
I mean, that's, she grew up on the Upper East Side, so she.
我的意思是，那是，她在上东区长大，所以她……
Oh, and then the four and five no longer stops at those exact stops or something.
哦，然后4号线和5号线不再精准停靠那些站了还是怎么的。
No, I think it does.
不，我觉得还是停的。
Maybe he does.
也许停吧。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
I thought it was an old tech moment.
我以为那是一个老地标的梗。
Or maybe it was the six, but go ahead.
或者也许是6号线，不过你接着说。
That's just saying that watching how I met your mother, when Barney says he's going to do this, and you see he's doing it, and Marshall is insisting that he's cheating.
我只是想说，看《老爸老妈浪漫史》时，当巴尼说他要这么做，而你看到他确实在这么做，并且马歇尔坚信他在作弊。
Your brain is swirling going, he's clearly, definitely cheating.
你的脑子就会飞速运转，心想：他很明显、绝对是在作弊。
He's definitely cheating.
他绝对是在作弊。
I can't wait to find out your sweetie.
我等不及要看你甜心被打脸了。
I thought he was cheating.
我当时以为他在作弊。
And there was almost a disappointment when it wasn't paying off, it wasn't happening, it wasn't happening.
当剧情没有按这个方向兑现、没有发生、没有发生时，甚至有一种失望感。
And then it raises the bar of how you have to pay off that story.
然后这就提高了你必须如何收尾这个故事的标准。
And I think we fucking nailed it.
我觉得我们他妈的做到了完美。
Because the dead legs thing is just a thing of beauty.
因为“死腿”那个桥段简直美妙绝伦。
It is just one of my favorite physical comedy moments on the whole series.
它绝对是我整部剧中最喜欢的肢体喜剧时刻之一。
And again, it's kind of like you gave Barney like you give him this triumph, right?
而且话说回来，这有点像是你给了巴尼一个胜利，对吧？
He gets this triumph, right?
他获得了这种胜利，对吧？
He's like, it's unbelievable.
他觉得，这简直难以置信。
He's walking around the city like he owns it, right?
他在城里走来走去，就像这里是他的地盘一样，对吧？
And then you take it away, like you show that like.
然后你把它夺走，就像你展现出……
Yeah, and it's funny too, because he's also like a real snob about the subway.
对，而且这也挺搞笑的，因为他对地铁也有一种真正的势利。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Even like in a pre-ooper age, he was just, he's riding, he's doing cab, he's doing car services.
甚至在网约车出现之前的时代，他也是，他坐车，他坐出租车，他坐专车。
What is the subway I've heard about?
我听说过的地铁是什么？
And the idea that he gets imprisoned, it really is Greek.
而他被关进监狱的这个设定，真的很有希腊悲剧色彩。
Like he gets, it's like old Greek mythology.
就像他被关进去，就像古希腊神话一样。
Like he gets imprisoned forever in the nether world of the city.
就像他永远被关在这座城市的冥界里。
In the underworld, he's the underworld.
在地下世界，他就是地下世界。
In the underworld, yeah.
在地下世界，对。
The river sticks.
冥河。
He's doomed to roam the river sticks.
他注定要在冥河游荡。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
I like it when the old woman calls him a douche.
我喜欢老妇人骂他混蛋的那段。
That was funny.
那太逗了。
That was a very abrupt douche.
那是一个非常突兀的“混蛋”。
But it was like, it was an old woman, a pregnant woman, and a kid on crutches.
但当时的情况是，有一个老妇人、一个孕妇和一个拄拐杖的小孩。
Like it just stacks the deck.
就像是把所有弱势群体都堆在一起。
Walk into a bar.
走进一家酒吧。
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
对，对，没错。
Fantastic.
太棒了。
Robin impersonating the car alarm, and then being driven to a place of madness by the car alarm, a madness and hopelessness.
罗宾模仿汽车警报器，然后被汽车警报器逼得快要疯掉，陷入疯狂和绝望。
They will never not, they can walk away at any point, by the way.
顺便说一句，他们其实随时都可以走人。
Yeah, they can leave at any point, but they don't want to live their place in line.
对，他们随时可以离开，但他们不想放弃排队的位置。
They don't want to live their place in line.
他们不想放弃排队的位置。
They like Barney.
他们喜欢巴尼。
You can't first can't move their paralyzed by it.
你不能——首先，他们动不了，被这情况瘫痪了。
And that's really funny.
这真的很好笑。
That really made me laugh when they were singing the song with the car alarm.
当他们伴着汽车警报声唱歌时，真的把我逗笑了。
Oh, Robin's trying to make it his game and we'll have fun with it.
哦，罗宾想把它变成自己的游戏，我们来找点乐子吧。
Lily starts crying.
莉莉开始哭泣。
That was so alley so funny in that moment.
那一刻阿莉（Aly）真的太搞笑了。
And the way they fucking hate that guy.
而且他们那种他妈的讨厌那家伙的态度。
Oh my guy who shows up beat beat the next morning.
哦，那个第二天早上出现并打败——打败了的家伙。
That's the guy.
就是那家伙。
He looks like the way you cast him.
他的长相，就像你选角的那个。
He He looks like the guy that turned Barney and Barney.
他——他看起来就像那个拒绝过巴尼的家伙。
Oh, that would have been such a great callback.
哦，那会是一个多么棒的经典回顾啊。
It should have been that guy.
本来就该是那个家伙。
I don't know if it was Robin, or no, it was Lily if we get through this, I'm going to live my life differently.
我不知道是罗宾，还是——不，是莉莉说：如果我们能挺过去，我要以完全不同的方式生活。
Yeah.
对。
I just want to tell my parents.
我只想告诉我的父母。
I love them one more time.
我最后一次爱他们。
Yeah.
对。
That is so funny.
太好笑了。
They can really leave at any point.
他们明明随时可以离开。
It's just a wedding dress, but they just, yeah.
那只是一件婚纱，但他们就是——对。
Yeah.
对。
You know what else I thought was a carbo loading is ancient.
你们知道我还觉得什么很搞笑吗？碳水化合物加载已经过时了。
Like no one recommends carbo loading.
就像现在没人推荐碳水化合物加载一样。
Like eating a plate of linguini before you go running a man his run where he drinks the breakfast and runs and then runs to the bathroom And vomit is like he's still very jonty as he's running Jason's so funny and really good physical comedy in there Jordana asked wait Jordana was like did he really drink that I was like no he didn't really drink it But they must have just given him like a little orange smoothie little orange juice or something maybe at the bottom of that, but he just runs so confidently that you really don't know he's going to vomit.
就像你在去跑步前吃了一盘扁面条，马歇尔跑步时喝了早餐然后去跑步，接着跑到卫生间呕吐，他跑步的时候看起来还是那么轻快，杰森太搞笑了，里面有很多非常棒的身体喜剧，乔丹娜问——等等，乔丹娜问他真的喝了那个吗？我说没有，他不是真的喝了。但他们肯定给了他一点橙色沙冰或橙汁之类的东西，可能在杯底，但他跑步时那么自信，你真的不知道他要吐。
So when he's psyching himself up in the mirror when Marshall is, so Jordana said, this is from the Terminator.
所以当他在镜子里给自己打气时，马歇尔在打气，乔丹娜说，这出自《终结者》。
No, the machine, I'm a machine from the future.
不，我是机器，我是一个来自未来的机器。
Yeah, that's kind of just a little Terminator, a little just Marshall loves robots.
对，那有点像《终结者》，有点像马歇尔喜欢机器人。
But it's Terminator meets like we are Marshall, right?
但这是《终结者》遇上了《我们是马歇尔》，对吧？
Yeah, exactly.
对，没错。
So it's two movie references jammed into one mirror shot.
所以这是把两个电影梗塞进了一个镜头的画面里。
And the one from the 80s holds up better than the We Are Marshall one does, right?
而且80年代的那部比《我们是马歇尔》经得起考验，对吧？
But I was like, right.
但我当时想，没错。
But I remember that movie was not, it had come out not too long before we were filming this.
但我记得那部电影并没有——我们拍这集的时候，它上映没多久。
It was kind of in the air then.
那时候它挺火的。
I don't know that it still is.
我不知道现在是不是还这样。
It was in the air, but I don't think a lot of people talk about that movie in orbit.
它当时挺火的，但我并不觉得现在有很多人在讨论那部电影。
It was like We Are Marshall was the big champ, right?
就像《我们尔是马歇尔》曾经是个大热门，对吧？
It was.
是的。
I never even saw it, but I know it was a thing and now it doesn't feel like that much of a thing.
我甚至都没看过，但我知道有这回事，现在感觉没那么大影响力了。
But okay, it's a shout out to that movie.
不过好吧，算是向那部电影致敬吧。
Yeah, just finally go watch our movie.
对，快去看我们的电影吧。
The shot of Marshall rubbing his nipples when Robin walks in is funny.
罗宾走进来时，马歇尔揉乳头的那个镜头太搞笑了。
So funny.
太搞笑了。
So silly.
太滑稽了。
There was a lot of falling down in this episode.
这一集里有好多摔倒的镜头。
You go down at least twice, Ted does.
泰德你至少摔了两次。
Barney a couple of times.
巴尼摔了好几次。
Barney at least won great one.
巴尼至少有一次很棒的。
Marshall's down, at least that one.
马歇尔也摔了，至少有那一次。
I do have a stunt note.
我确实对特技有个意见。
The way that Marshall falls does not look like he would have broken his toe.
马歇尔摔倒的方式看起来并不像是会把脚趾摔断的。
Right.
没错。
He broken his fucking back.
他他妈的会把背摔断。
He would have like hurt his like his sacrum or something.
他应该会伤到他的骶骨什么的。
It was a funny fall, but it didn't look like a toe fall.
那是一个好笑的摔倒，但看起来不像会伤到脚趾的摔倒。
It didn't look like a toe fall.
看起来不像会伤到脚趾的摔倒。
Unless, here's what I could, here's what I make, a score.
除非，我能这样解释，我编个分数。
He falls and his foot kicks into the toilet.
他摔倒时，脚踢进了马桶里。
Yeah, exactly.
对，没错。
And with a really high impact.
而且冲击力非常大。
That's the only way.
只有这样。
只有这样才说得通。
I broke my toe on a kitchen chair and they're like just walking around the kitchen last summer and that is exactly how it had.
我去年夏天在厨房椅子上摔断过脚趾，当时就是随便在厨房走走，事情就是那样发生的。
I just like full force and do a kitchen chair like it can happen.
我就是全力撞到厨房椅子上——这种事确实会发生。
Another old ref that I actually like that might be a little more in the air right now, but Lilly makes a reference to Lilith Fair, the line at Lilith Fair in 1998.
另一个老梗我也很喜欢，现在可能更应景一点，莉莉提到了莉莉丝音乐节（Lilith Fair），1998年莉莉丝音乐节的长队。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Which by the way, I don't know if we talked about this, but my wife and I watched that documentary on Lilith Fair, which is fantastic.
顺便说一句，我不知道我们有没有聊过这个，我和我太太看了关于莉莉丝音乐节的那部纪录片，太棒了。
Oh cool.
哦，酷。
And really worth watching.
真的非常值得一看。
Okay, I'll check that out.
好吧，我去看看。
That was a big deal in the late 90s and came back around, right?
这在90年代末可是个大事，后来又卷土重来了，对吧？
That's what you're saying.
你是这么说的。
Well, I don't know if they might have redone it, but they made a documentary about it, which is really terrific.
嗯，我不知道他们是不是重拍了，但他们拍了一部关于它的纪录片，真的很棒。
Cool, I'll check that out.
酷，我去看看。
Yeah.
对。
That was a funny reference.
那是个有趣的梗。
That's a good old rep.
那是个老牌的赞誉。
I stand by that one.
我坚持那个说法。
That one was a little fair.
那个稍微有点勉强。
Yeah.
对。
I thought the woman, both people at the gate, the airport were terrific.
我觉得那个女的，登机口的那两个人，机场的那两个人都棒极了。
Both funny, again, both really funny.
两个人都很有趣，再说一次，两个人都超级搞笑。
Come in if you're an actor and just try to kill that part.
如果你是个演员，进组就得努力把这个角色演好。
She was very charming and funny and we probably gave her more lines because she just was like, you knew you were in good hands.
她非常有魅力也很有趣，我们可能给她加了更多台词，因为她给人的感觉就是，你知道自己遇到靠谱的人了。
You're certainly not taking away lines if someone's that good.
如果有人这么优秀，你当然不会删台词。
And the dude, the second guy who also doesn't let them on the plan, he was really funny.
还有那个男的，第二个不让他们登机的家伙，他真的很好笑。
Yeah.
对。
I think Tina Fey, I think it was on Amy Poehler's podcast, but she was talking about like things she loves.
我觉得蒂娜·菲，好像是在艾米·波勒的播客上，她当时在谈论她喜欢的东西。
I think we talked about this in season one, but she talks about like, I think she lives in New Jersey or New York somewhere, but there's like a local New York kind of morning show that she's obsessed with.
我想我们在第一季里聊过这个，但她说的是，我觉得她住在新泽西或纽约的某个地方，但有一个她着迷的纽约本地早间节目。
Yeah.
对。
And there are two anchors that she's particularly obsessed with and has had one or both of them come to many premieres of Tina Fey stuff.
有两个她特别痴迷的主持人，而且其中一个或两个都出席了蒂娜·菲很多作品的首映礼。
Yeah.
对。
But there's a very particular personality that's like a morning show person.
但有一种非常独特的性格，就是那种早间节目主持人的性格。
Yeah.
对。
That like really gets into it.
那种真的很投入的人。
And that guy just played that archetype.
而那个家伙完美地演出了那种原型。
Like, oh my God.
天呐。
Because also the show's on it, like 430 or five.
因为节目也是在4:30或者5点左右播出的。
Yeah.
对。
Like he's clearly a morning riser that throws on his like fun and ridiculous.
他显然是个早起的人，穿上他那套有趣又荒谬的衣服。
There's nothing else to watch.
没别的可看了。
Yeah.
对。
And Robin, the way Robin gets giddy whenever she gets recognized.
还有罗宾，罗宾每次一被人认出来就兴奋得不行的那个样子。
Oh my God.
天呐。
And she's just, Kobe is very funny.
她真的很搞笑，寇碧非常有意思。
It's the most anonymous way to be on television.
这是上电视最没有存在感的方式了。
You could ever be on television.
你能在电视上表现得最没有存在感。
She can never believe it that she's recognized, but it's so, so needy of what's happening.
她简直不敢相信自己会被认出来，但这实在是，对发生的一切太渴望了。
Was there ever anyone that did like a compilation of all the names of Robin's Morning Show?
有没有人做过罗宾早间节目所有名字的剪辑合集？
Because it was like, wake up New York.
因为里面有诸如“醒醒吧纽约”之类的话。
Get up New.
“起床吧纽约”。
Send those to us if anyone has.
如果有人有的话，发给我们。
There was a bunch of them.
有很多这样的名字。
Yeah.
对。
Those are really funny.
那些真的很好笑。
By the way, Crick, shout out to Meredith Scott Lynn.
顺便说一句，柯里克，向梅雷迪思·斯科特·林致敬。
She's the one that plays.
就是她扮演的。
Oh yes, yes.
哦，对，对。
She was terrific.
她太棒了。
Really funny and a delight on set.
真的很有趣，在片场也很让人开心。
Throwing it away, you know, not pushing.
演得很自然，你知道的，没有用力过猛。
Sometimes people come into those smaller parts and like, try to, this is my one thing I got a nail in.
有时人们演这些小角色时会想，试着……这是我唯一能大显身手的机会。
She was very throwing it all away, very casual, and that was what worked and was funny.
她演得很自然，非常随性，而这正是起作用且搞笑的地方。
I also thought her faints of like thinking that she was getting around the plane, but it was always talking to her mom.
我还觉得她假装自己能上飞机，但其实一直在跟她妈妈打电话的那些桥段。
Those were really funny.
那些真的很好笑。
I also really liked Kobe's trying to walk back, like surely you didn't dream of being, you know, and then having to kind of walk, but your outfit's really pretty.
我也很喜欢寇碧试图打圆场，比如“你肯定没梦想过成为……”之类的，然后不得不圆过去，“不过你的衣服真漂亮。”
Yeah, Kobe was always, I was just about to say, Kobe was always really funny when she stepped in it.
对，寇碧总是……我正要说呢，寇碧每次犯窘的时候都特别搞笑。
And then it's like, it literally remember when she stepped in it.
然后就像是……简直记不得她是什么时候犯窘的了。
Like in, in season, you literally have it.
就像在……在某一季里，你简直能想起来。
Yeah.
对。
I, again, another like little improvisation, these are so small, but because they were so little room for improvisation, but when, when Kobe and I were walking with the hot dog that, that the Lucky Penny paid for.
我，再次提到，另一个即兴表演的小细节，这些都太微不足道了，但因为即兴发挥的空间很小，然而当寇碧和我拿着那根幸运便士付钱买的热狗散步时。
Yeah.
对。
And she says something like in however many years, maybe we'll get like 30 years, we'll be able to get another hot dog or something.
她说了类似“在不知多少年以后，也许三十年后，我们就能再买一根热狗了”这样的话。
Yeah.
对。
And I said, how dare you, but I don't think that was in the script.
我说“你怎么敢这样”，但我觉得剧本里没有这句。
I think that was just like something I either said.
我觉得那只是我随口说出的某句话。
And she laughed in a very natural way because it wasn't in the script.
她笑得很自然，因为那不在剧本里。
And it's funny, you can spot those moments, those little moments where you can see her being surprised by it.
很有趣，你能发现那些时刻，那些你能看到她对此感到惊讶的小瞬间。
It was very charming, it was very cute, the two of you.
非常迷人，非常可爱，你们俩。
It's a good Ted and Robin in it together episode, even though you are kind of going, well, wait a second, what if he goes to Chicago and somehow he gets to, like there's a little bit of a sign of what would happen if he had to move to Chicago?
这是一集很好的泰德和罗宾一起出场的剧集，尽管你可能会想，等一下，如果他去芝加哥，不知怎么的他去了……就像是有一种迹象表明，如果他不得不搬去芝加哥会发生什么？
I know the stakes of this are not, he's gonna move to Chicago.
我知道这集的赌注不是他要搬去芝加哥。
He's gonna Chicago to get a job in New York.
他是要去芝加哥争取一份在纽约的工作。
Well, you don't realize it.
嗯，你没意识到这一点。
Like, I thought that he was, maybe I missed the line.
比如，我以为他是……也许我漏听了一句台词。
I think maybe Narrator Ted says, I was interviewing with a Chicago firm to be in New York, to stay in New York.
我觉得可能是旁白泰德说，我在面试一家芝加哥的公司，为了能在纽约工作，留在纽约。
Stay come back to New York.
留在纽约，回到纽约。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
And run their New York office, right?
然后管理他们的纽约办公室，对吧？
Right, yes.
对，没错。
Those were the stakes and it was spelled out.
这就是当时的赌注，而且交代得很清楚。
We didn't really, like I like the Ted that Robin was gonna go with him.
我们其实没有……我喜欢罗宾要跟他一起去的那个泰德。
I know.
我知道。
I like that too.
我也很喜欢那样。
So they almost felt like we should have made more of that.
所以他们几乎觉得我们本该在这上面着墨更多。
Like that's a big step forward in their relationship.
就像那是他们关系中的一大步。
They've probably never gone away for a little two-day trip to anywhere.
他们可能从来没有一起去任何地方进行过为期两天的短途旅行。
And we kind of skipped over that, but I liked it anyway.
我们有点把这部分跳过去了，但我还是很喜欢。
I liked the energy of it.
我喜欢那种活力。
It shows you that their relationship is escalating.
它向你展示了他们的关系在升级。
I liked that she was as desperate to get on the plane as he was.
我喜欢她和泰德一样急着想上飞机。
She wanted her.
她很想去。
She had taken on the urgency of my fella needs to get to Chicago, and it was in a meta lot to her.
她承载了“我的男人需要去芝加哥”的紧迫感，这证明这对她意义重大。
Yeah, because she relates, she's ambitious.
对，因为她能感同身受，她很有野心。
And she's like, this is a great opportunity for Daddy's killing it, and he's being headhunted, which also is cool, it's cool.
她会想，这对我家大男孩来说是个绝佳的机会，他大展身手了，而且他正在被高薪挖角，这也很酷，真的很酷。
Again, I forgot in this season how much Ted's career is kind of in the air of this season.
再说一次，我忘了这一季里泰德的职业生涯在这一季占了多大比重。
Like Ted's architect career is very present.
就像泰德的建筑师职业生涯非常突显。
Even in this episode, everything is being driven by that.
甚至在这集里，一切都是由这个驱动的。
I forgot how true that was of this season.
我忘了这一季这有多真实。
I like it, I like that it's another speed, because Ted's not out dating, he's with Robin.
我喜欢，我喜欢这是另一种节奏，因为泰德没有在约会，他和罗宾在一起。
So we need other shit for Ted while it's career.
所以当泰德处于那个职业生涯阶段时，我们需要别的东西。
Yeah, when they were running to the gate, I said to my wife, I said, This is how you're supposed to arrive at the airport.
对，当他们奔向登机口时，我对妻子说，我说，这才是去机场应有的方式。
And this was not good for her to hear.
而且她听到这个可高兴不起来。
I mean, as a joke, just because she is a, and I think this is our olive theory.
我是说，当个玩笑而已，因为她是个……我觉得这就是我们的“橄榄理论”。
This is me and my wife's olive theory.
这就是我和我老婆的橄榄理论。
I want to be at the gate for no time.
我希望提前一秒也不要在登机口等。
I want to walk through security.
我只想走过安检。
I want to walk out to the plane.
我只想直接走向飞机。
So I sometimes go to the airport too late.
所以我有时去机场太晚了。
I'm Jordana in this one.
在这件事上我就是若丹娜（Jordana）。
I cannot do that.
我可做不到那样。
She wants to get there four hours early.
她想提前四个小时到那。
Oh yeah.
哦，对。
And sit and wait at the gate, which I think is absurd, but we're still married.
然后在登机口坐着干等，我觉得这太荒谬了，但我们居然还没离婚。
How often do you miss glitz though?
不过你们错失航班的频率有多高？
We've only missed one, but I'll tell you why, because I had a thing that she came to me with in Canada.
我们只错过了一次，但我来告诉你原因，因为在加拿大时，她跟我提过一件事。
I performed at a benefit in Canada, and she, we didn't realize that the Canadian cutoff was different, like the, it was different than America.
我在加拿大参加了一个慈善义演，而她……我们当时没意识到加拿大的截止时间不一样，就像……它跟美国不一样。
I was like Thanksgiving, it's earlier.
我觉得就像感恩节一样，时间更早。
It was an early flight, But here's the, this is our lucky penny.
那是个早班机，但关键是——这就是我们的“幸运硬币”。
I wonder if she's listening to this right now and laughing, she's probably gonna burst in and say, no, that was wrong.
我在想她现在是不是在听这个节目然后笑呢，她可能会突然闯进来，说，不对，那不是真的。
She doesn't sound like that.
她才不是那种语气呢。
Is she texting me?
她是在给我发信息吗？
No, she's not watching the text.
不，她没在看手机。
But in the morning, when we were leaving the hotel, she stopped, she said, wait, I just wanna grab a coffee.
但在早上，当我们离开酒店时，她停下来，她说，等等，我只想去买杯咖啡。
Like they had coffee out.
就像他们把咖啡摆在外面那样。
So she grabbed a coffee.
于是她就去拿了一杯咖啡。
She is listening.
她在听。
Josh, she's listening.
乔希，她在听。
As you talk to him right now.
就在你现在跟他说话的时候。
I'll cap them listening.
我会随时关注她有没有在听。
So watch your words right now.
所以你现在说话注意点。
So she gets a cup of coffee and then we go to the airport.
于是她拿了一杯咖啡，然后我们去了机场。
Oh, please, Josh, I'm gonna get her reactions in real time.
哦，拜托，乔希，我要实时看到她的反应了。
We missed the flight by literally like, it was like 45 seconds.
我们错过航班的时间简直只有……大概45秒。
Like it had just closed and it was one of those things like we can't override the baggage cut off or whatever it was.
就像是刚办完登机手续就关闭了，属于那种我们无法覆盖行李托运截止时间之类的情况。
That's hilarious.
太搞笑了。
And I have always said, well, if you didn't stop to get that cup of coffee, this is like two years ago, by the way.
我一直说，好吧，如果你没有停下来买那杯咖啡——顺便说一句，这已经是两年前的事了。
You know, this is madness.
你知道，这太疯狂了。
You know, you're just looking for trouble here.
你知道的，你这就是自找麻烦。
This is longer than two years ago.
这远不止两年前了。
But yes, but this has been a running argument.
不过是的，但这是一个一直都在争论的话题。
You lived a lucky penny.
你们经历过“幸运硬币”。
That's really funny.
那真的太逗了。
Yeah, that's really funny.
对，真的太逗了。
But then we, there was another flight like 90 minutes later that we got on, so we just ended up having breakfast and it ended up to be a fine morning and we got to back back to New York.
但后来我们……还有另一个航班在90分钟后起飞，我们搭上了那个，所以我们最后吃了早餐，结果倒也是个不错的早晨，而且我们回到了纽约。
I'm just trying to see if Jordana is weighing in and saying, Oh fuck you.
我只是想看看若丹娜有没有在参与讨论并说，“去你的吧”。
Yeah, see what Jordana would like to say, but now he comes to the airport early with me.
对，看看若丹娜会说些什么，但现在他跟我一样早早去机场了。
And enjoy the truth.
并且享受真相。
All the truth, all counts.
所有的真相，每一个字都算数。
She changed you.
她改变了你。
You're a changed man.
你变了个人。
Shaming me.
真丢脸。
She's helped you evolve.
她帮你进化了。
That's what I mean.
这就是我的意思。
No, you guys, yeah, tell the truth.
不，你们这些家伙，对，说出真相。
Oh, please, Josh, she says, I can't.
哦，拜托，乔希，她说，我做不到。
She is listening to me.
她真的在听我说话。
We're gonna paint the picture.
我们要还原一下现场。
She is in another room listening to this and texting.
她在另一个房间里听着节目并一边发信息。
She has it off on the computer in the background.
她把电脑背景里的音频开着。
This is really true.
这千真万确。
She likes listening sometimes when you're recording, so she's texting in some clarifications.
她有时喜欢在你们录音的时候听，所以她发了一些澄清的信息进来。
Yeah, it's like shaming and clarifications from a clinical psychologist, who's never seen how I met Your mother also happens to be married to children.
对，这就好像来自一位临床心理学家的羞辱和澄清，她从来没看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》，碰巧还嫁给了孩子他爸。
Hello, Al.
哈喽，阿尔。
She's enjoying this.
她很享受这个。
I really like the work.
我真的很喜欢这工作。
This is now a podcast where we just get texts from the other ones.
这现在成了一个我们只管收听另一半发来的短信的播客了。
And this old man.
还有这个老头。
He musted me.
他把我弄糊涂了。
Fell in love with you.
爱上了你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，是广告时间。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈尔德曼，也就是播客《纠结终结者》的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们会收集听众的问题并试着帮他们解决。
like, I'm 30, and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如，我30岁了，但在纽约开车我感到害怕。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么当我挂倒车档时，我不能调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car-related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有一个问题，我们不仅会解决它，还会揭示导致该问题背后的隐藏机制。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的《纠结终结者》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在任何收听播客的地方找到它，或者登录HyperFixedPod.com。
End of commercials?
广告结束？
Back to show.
回到节目。
By the way, we have text coming in hot.
顺便说一句，我们正不断收到火热的短信。
I'm texting with Carter now.
我现在正在和卡特发短信。
Okay, here's a clarification and unaware of the Barney story from Carter is texting me.
好的，这里有一个澄清，卡特发短信给我说他并不了解巴尼的故事。
I said, wait, did you know the guy that had happened to?
我说，等等，你知道那个遭遇这种事的人是谁吗？
And he says, LOL, I think I heard that story on a date.
他说，哈哈，我想我是在一次约会中听过这个故事。
No idea how true it is, but as soon as I heard it, I knew we'd be using it on the show.
完全不知道真实性如何，但一听到它，我就知道我们会在剧里用上它。
So, okay, we can't, I take it back.
所以，好吧，我们不能……我收回刚才的话。
We don't know for sure that a guy did it, but he didn't hear from a date that it happened.
我们并不确定是不是真有这样一个人，但他确实是从一次约会中听说过这件事。
Well, you know, it's funny.
嗯，你知道的，这很有趣。
So somewhere out there, there's a guy who ran a marathon and lost the usage legs, right?
所以在某个地方，确实有一个跑了马拉松然后导致双腿暂时瘫痪的家伙，对吧？
For a time.
有一段时间是这样的。
Okay.
好吧。
With the hubris of I can run the marathon without training.
带着“我不训练也能跑马拉松”的盲目自大。
That part is, here's what happened to me constantly.
那部分是……以下是我经常遇到的情况。
Yeah.
对。
When you guys started taking stuff from my life and making it Ted.
当你们这些家伙开始从我的生活中取材并把它变成泰德的经历时。
Yeah.
是啊。
So that guy is out there telling this story.
所以那家伙到处讲这个故事。
Like, this is the craziest story that ever happened to me.
就好像，这是我经历过最疯狂的事。
I decided I could run a marathon.
我决定去跑马拉松。
I ran it, I finished it, and then I lost the use of my legs.
我跑了，我跑完了，然后我的腿就动不了了。
People were like, Oh my God, just like how I met your boss.
大家就说，天哪，这简直就像《老爸老妈浪漫史》里的情节。
And he's like, No, that's my story.
然后他说，不，那是我的故事。
That was my story.
那是我的故事。
Faith, you're right about that.
费斯，你这话没错。
Yeah, you're right about that.
对，你说的对。
You know?
你知道吗？
It's really weird.
这真的很奇怪。
All these things.
所有这些事情。
Now they've been in the pop culture for 19, 20 years.
现在它们已经进入流行文化19、20年了。
And Carter says, and yes, in the story, this guy was stuck sitting on the subway for hours.
卡特说，是的，在故事里，这家伙在地铁里被困了好几个小时。
So that subway part was part of it.
所以地铁那部分是其中一部分。
Okay.
好吧。
I mean, it's funny that like the truest stuff is the best stuff.
我的意思是，有趣的是，往往最真实的东西才是最好的。
And it often seems like the most far-fetched.
而且它通常看起来最不可思议。
It is like truth is stranger than fiction.
这就叫现实比小说更离奇。
Like if you had to choose a part of this episode that happened, the one real part of this whole episode, when you have said the guy that ran the marathon and got stuck on the subway.
如果让你选择这集里发生的事，整集里唯一真实的部分，你会认为是那个跑了马拉松然后被困在地铁里的家伙吗？
No, you'd be like the 1939 penny.
不，你会觉得是那个1939年的便士。
Right, any other part would make a true part.
对，其他任何部分听起来都更像真的。
And I don't think there's one other true part besides that story, which again, I hope is true from some date Carter and 25 years ago.
我不认为除了那个故事之外还有什么是真的，再次说明，我希望卡特25年前记录的那个日期是真的。
It's incredible.
这太不可思议了。
But it also shows that Carter has an appropriately sticky writer mind, which is like, if you're a writer, you have a file in your head that is like a great title, great scenario, great character, tick, like they're always going in.
但也表明卡特有着一个极其敏锐的编剧大脑，也就是说，如果你是个编剧，你脑子里有个文件夹，里面装着好标题、好设定、好角色，就像打卡一样，它们总是不断涌入。
And when you find the right place for them, It's delightful.
当你为它们找到合适的位置时，那感觉太美妙了。
I think the idea that there was some special wedding dress sale was like that that exists.
我觉得有什么特别的婚纱大减卖之类的点子，现实中也是存在的。
Someone had a story like that, but it wasn't exactly like, there was a few like little kernels of truth in here, but the realest thing was the thing that seems the most absolutely made up.
有人经历过类似的事，但又不太完全一样，这里面有一些微小的真实内核，但最真实的东西反而是看起来最像编造出来的那个。
Well, this is a great example of a, I guess I wonder if I would love to find like a name for these kinds of episodes.
嗯，这是一个很好的例子，我在想我是不是能为这类剧集起个名字。
Like I always call it like, this isn't quite that, but like filling in the lore episodes, kind of like how I met everyone else is a great filling in the lore, you know, even showing like how Barney became, I really like how you guys run with Barney as a gambling addiction.
就像我总是管它叫——虽然不太贴切——但有点像“补充背景设定”的剧集，有点像《老爸老妈漫长回忆》那种极好的补充设定，你知道的，甚至还展示了巴尼是怎么变成那样的，我真的很喜欢你们把巴尼好赌当成一个长期设定来玩。
Like once you got that, it was like a very reliable well to draw.
一旦你抓住了这一点，它就像一口能量满满、可以不断汲取的水井。
His turns on, okay, 50 bucks, he's so good at that.
他转过头来，好吧，50块，他太擅长这个了。
In the X-Files world, there's the mythology versus the monster of the week episodes.
在《X档案》的世界里，有主线神话集与每周怪物集的区别。
You have very few monster of the week episodes, even if the network and studio wanted more of those and more mythology.
你们很少有每周怪物集的剧集，尽管电视网和制片厂希望有更多那种剧集和更多的主线神话。
That's right, that's right.
没错，没错。
And we just, and I'm like, I've said this on here before, I'm very proud of Carter and I that we just, we stuck with the mythology piece more than the can, the box of candies.
我们只是——我以前在这里说过——我为卡特和我感到非常自豪，我们坚持了神话主线，而不是那些糖果盒。
You know, I would argue that like Monster of the Week, I understand why networks would demand them because they're trying to get people who just stumble across it and can watch a self-contained episode for 22 minutes or 48 minutes or whatever.
你知道的，我可以说，对于每周怪物集，我理解为什么电视网会要求它们，因为他们想吸引那些偶然看到、能看22分钟或48分钟等独立一集的人。
But if you want to create a show that lasts that people are watching 20 years later, it's got to have mythology.
但如果你想创作一部能持续下去、让人们在20年后还在看的剧，它就必须有主线神话。
Like I don't think any show that people still talk about a decade after it went off the air, I think it has to have mythology to it.
我觉得任何在剧集完结十年后人们还在讨论的剧，它都必须具备神话般的背景设定。
Yeah, totally.
对，完全同意。
But I love that this episode has a mythology piece and I also love that it is the best of both worlds.
但我喜欢这集既有一个神话主线，我也喜欢它兼具两者的优点。
It is everybody's on one thing.
每个人都在做同一件事。
Everybody's on this one through line and is there kind of all on the same train track to steal the part of the train metaphor of the episode itself?
每个人都在这条共同的主线上，他们是不是有点像在同一条铁轨上，借用一下这集本身的火车隐喻？
They're all kind of together, but each person also has their own little vignette that's very much their own thing.
他们都在某种程度上聚在一起，但每个人也都有自己非常独特的小插曲。
It is a great balance of two things where everybody has a thing and they're also all in the same thing at the same time.
这是两全其美的完美平衡，每个人都有自己的事，同时他们又都在同一时间经历着同一件事。
It's the best of both worlds.
这是两全其美的。
But it also all arises out of their character.
但这一切也都源于他们的性格。
Like Barney's plot line arises out of his hubris and Ted's plot line arises out of his love of old things.
比如巴尼的剧情源于他的傲慢，而泰德的剧情源于他对老旧事物的热爱。
And Lilly is, I mean, she has very expensive tastes very expensive tastes and she has a kindergartners teaching salary, like she's trying to navigate.
莉莉的品味非常高，我是说，她有着非常昂贵的品味，而且她拿着幼儿园老师的薪水，她正在努力应付这一切。
And they're getting married.
而且他们要结婚了。
It keeps alive their wedding.
这让他们的婚礼得以继续。
And they're getting married in Marshall's in law school and presumably taking out loans.
而且马歇尔在读法学院，他们还要结婚，大概还要贷款。
She's really trying to navigate how to make her way through that.
她真的在努力设法应付那种状况。
It all comes from characters.
这一切都源于角色。
So even Marshall's getting married.
所以甚至连马歇尔也在准备结婚。
He doesn't want to have a tummy.
他不想长啤酒肚。
He doesn't want to be an old, like, doughy married guy.
他不想变成一个老态龙钟、软绵绵的已婚男人。
He's like, no, I have to change my body around.
他心想，不，我必须改变我的身材。
Like, all of it comes from, yeah, comes from character.
总之，这一切都源于，是的，都源于角色。
And this also, this is the kind of episode where you have to have 35 episodes under your belt to do this kind of episode.
而且这也一样，这是一集需要你拍过35集之后才能驾驭的剧集。
Like, you could not do this in the opening 12 episodes, like you just don't know enough about the characters and you're not invested enough.
比如说，你不能在前12集里这么做，因为你对角色还不够了解，投入的情感也还不够深。
So I think this is like, this to me was an episode where it was like season two was like all guns firing.
所以我认为这就像是，对我来说这就是那种第二季全面火力全开的剧集。
Like, this feels like a really, really good example of what the show was at its best and where it was headed and what it did differently than any other show on the air at the time.
这感觉就像是一个非常非常好的例子，展示了这部剧在巅峰时期的状态，它未来的方向，以及它与当时播出的任何其他剧集有何不同。
Yeah, and this one holds up really well.
是的，这一集经受住了时间的考验。
I'm really proud of this one.
我真的为这一集感到骄傲。
And yeah, it's a great TED episode too.
而且，这也是一集很棒的泰德剧集。
It's all driven by TED's career.
整个故事都是由泰德的事业驱动的。
There's this action movie, suspenseful thing happening in the present, Robin and Ted are very much together.
现在发生了一件动作片般悬疑的事情，罗宾和泰德正处于热恋中。
It escalates their relationship.
这升级了他们的关系。
It keeps the live Marshall and the other game married.
这让马歇尔和其他人的婚礼得以继续。
There's so many boxes, this is jacking and little subtle ones too.
这里面有太多的元素，还有那些巧妙而微小的细节。
It really, yeah.
真的，是的。
You know, I came up with a big idea for something and I was talking to a friend of mine who has such a wild imagination, like such a good imagination.
你知道的，我曾经想出了一个关于某种东西的宏大点子，我当时在和我的一个朋友聊天，他有着极其丰富的想象力，想象力非常好。
We were talking about maybe collaborating on this thing, but he doesn't think dramatically or dramaturgically, he thinks just in these big, beautiful kind of images and themes.
我们当时在讨论也许可以合作这个项目，但他思考问题的方式不是戏剧性或戏剧结构层面的，他只是从那些宏大、美丽的意象和主题出发来思考。
And I was just trying to explain him the basics of drama, which is like the characters all have to want something, something has to be in the way of them getting what they want and they have to adjust their behavior to get what they want.
我当时只是在试着向他解释戏剧的基本原理，也就是所有角色都必须有所求，必须有什么东西阻碍他们得到他们想要的东西，而且他们必须调整自己的行为来得到他们想要的东西。
Yeah.
是的。
And you see, like, from the get-go, it's like Ted and Ron got to get on this plane.
你可以看到，从一开始，泰德和罗宾就必须赶上这架飞机。
Why has this job interview and he thinks it's his destiny?
为什么会有这场工作面试，而他认为这是他的命运？
They're late.
他们迟到了。
Why are they late?
他们为什么迟到？
Okay.
好吧。
So what do they do?
那他们该怎么办？
How do they talk to these gate, these literal gatekeepers?
他们是怎么和这些登机口人员，这些字面意义上的守门人交流的？
You know, like, how do they try, how do this is their behavior adapt and change?
你知道的，比如，他们是如何尝试的，他们的行为是如何调整和改变的？
Like, you could really, you really can map out the wants and the obstacles.
就像，你真的可以把他们想要的和遇到的障碍规划出来。
It's very Greek mythology.
这非常具有古希腊神话的色彩。
It's a very Greek mythology down to there being a marathon and a medal, Barney's stripped of his medal at the end.
这太像古希腊神话了，甚至还有马拉松和奖牌，巴尼最后还被剥夺了奖牌。
Like there's a prize, the prize has taken away.
就像有一个奖品，而奖品又被拿走了。
The gatekeeper, their gatekeepers.
守门人，他们就是守门人。
It is very like Greek, ancient Greek drama shit.
这真的很像古希腊戏剧的狗血桥段。
And it's also about like transportation and trying to get places that you can't get to.
而且这也是关于交通运输的，试图去到那些你无法到达的地方。
Yeah.
是的。
It always feels like a dream.
这感觉总像是一个梦。
Like the mythology of like, don't see where the subway turns around.
就像那种神话一样，不要去看地铁是在哪里调头的。
And Barney's stuck in a purgatory.
而巴尼被困在了炼狱里。
Like there's a lot, there's a lot of like ancient drama happening in this.
这里面有很多很多类似于古希腊戏剧的元素。
I want to give one other shout out, which is, we don't say this enough, our production team for this episode, like the set design, just everything about this episode, that airport was huge.
我想对另一件事表达感谢，那就是，我们平时说得不够多，这一集的制作团队，比如布景设计，关于这一集的方方面面，那个机场真的是太大了。
That has to be that heat up half of stage 22 when we built, because you guys are making left turns and running down a hallway and like, that's an enormous feat to make a set where you can actually run through the set.
当我们搭建布景时，它肯定占用了22号摄影棚的一半空间，因为你们要左转并跑过一条走廊，建造一个真正可以在里面奔跑的布景，这真是一项巨大的壮举。
I'm sure we had to do things like have that big line of smart cards block you, because we would have run out of set otherwise, like we need to slow Ted and Robin down.
我敢说我们当时肯定得搞个那种大智能卡排队栏来挡住你，不然景就穿帮了，因为我们需要放慢泰德和罗宾的脚步。
But like those tracking shots through that means that was a huge fucking set.
但那些穿梭镜头说明那绝对是个超级无敌大的布景。
Then it's like, and this is how amazing our production team is, build us that big of a set that we can have action, you know, a chase scene through an airport.
然后就会觉得，我们的制作团队太牛了，居然能搭建出一个这么大的布景，让我们能在里面拍动作戏，你知道的，一场穿过机场的追逐戏。
And then by the way, the next day we need a subway car.
然后顺便说一句，第二天我们需要一节地铁车厢。
This might have been one where we used stage 21.
这集可能用到了21号摄影棚。
This might have been one where they get one car with the subway car.
这集他们可能只搞到了一节地铁车厢。
It's coming back to me right now.
我这会儿想起来了。
Every now and again, we'd be so ambitious.
时不时地，我们的野心就会变得很大。
We'd have to like use part of the adjacent, the next sound stage over, which luckily was often like more of an influx.
我们不得不占用旁边相邻的下一个摄影棚，幸运的是，那个棚通常更像是一个临时周转区。
It wasn't always a long running show there.
那里并不总是有长期播出的节目。
so we could like ask for help and get extra space.
所以我们可以去寻求帮助并获得额外的空间。
Just a huge shout out to Susie Greenberg, Steve Olson, the whole production team was amazing in this episode.
特别鸣谢苏茜·格林伯格、史蒂夫·奥尔森，整支制作团队在这集里的表现简直太棒了。
Like think about how much is happening in terms of setting.
想想看，在布景的搭建上有多少工作量。
And I want to stress that we would leave on like a Wednesday after shooting or leave after Tuesday.
我想强调的是，我们通常在拍完后的周三离开，或者周二拍完就离开。
Nine o'clock, 10 o'clock at night, yeah.
晚上九点、十点左右，对吧。
And you'd come back the next morning and there'd be an airport.
然后你第二天早上回来，就会发现那里凭空多了一个机场。
Yeah.
对。
Here's an entire airport.
这里居然有一个完整的机场。
with multiple locations, like it was so, it was such weird magic that these sets would come up and go away so quickly.
而且包含多个场景，这简直就像某种诡异的魔法，这些布景出现和消失得如此之快。
Yeah, amazing.
对，太神奇了。
So that's a huge part of what was special about our show.
所以，这也是我们节目与众不同的巨大一部分。
All right, we're winding things down here for today, but we're going to end this episode as we end almost all episodes, which is we're gonna read a letter that we received from a fan of the show and a fan of the podcast.
好了，我们今天差不多要收尾了，但我们要像几乎所有节目一样，用一封信来结束这一集，也就是读一封我们收到的来自剧迷和播客粉丝的信。
If you would like to let us know what how I met your mother means to you, why you watch it over and over again, why you're loving this podcast, watching it with us all over again.
如果你想让我们知道《老爸老妈浪漫史》对你意味着什么，你为什么一遍又一遍地看，为什么你如此热爱这个播客，和我们一起重温这部剧。
Yeah, let us know what how I met your mother means to you, just go to how we madeyourmother.com, h-w-m-y-m.com and go to contact and should be pretty self-explanatory.
对，让我们知道《老爸老妈浪漫史》对你意味着什么，只需访问 howwemakeyourmother.com，即 h-w-m-y-m.com，然后点击联系我们，应该很容易懂。
Leave us a voice note, leave us a written letter.
给我们留个语音便签，或者写封信。
We love to, it's one of our favorite things is to hear from people who've loved the show for many years or even people who've just now discovering it.
我们非常喜欢，这是我们最喜欢的事情之一，就是听到那些多年来一直热爱这部剧的人，甚至是那些刚刚发现这部剧的人的心声。
Craig, anything to add?
克雷格，有什么要补充的吗？
No, I just said it's my favorite part of the whole thing of doing this podcast.
没有，我只想说这是我做这个播客最喜欢的部分。
Yeah, it's great.
对，这太棒了。
So please, let's dive in.
那么请吧，让我们深入其中。
Let's hear a cool letter from a quote.
来听一听粉丝来信中很酷的内容。
Okay, well, our letter today is from Julia and she writes, Dear Josh and Craig, first, I'd like to congratulate you both on such a lovely first season of the podcast.
好吧，我们今天的信来自茱莉亚，她写道：亲爱的乔希和克雷格，首先，我想祝贺你们俩完成了如此精彩的播客第一季。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I really admire how you both speak with such wisdom and clarity and have been fascinated by backstories on the production of the show.
我真的很佩服你们俩说话时展现出的智慧与清晰，而且我对这部剧制作背后的故事一直非常着迷。
My love for Hymmium began in middle school.
我对《老妈》的热爱始于初中。
Like most younger siblings, I stole many personality aspects from my older brothers, music taste, books, TV shows, and most importantly, Hymmium.
就像大多数年幼的弟弟妹妹一样，我从我哥哥那里偷学了很多个性特点，音乐品味、书籍、电视剧，最重要的是，还有《老妈》。
I used to watch the show with them after school on our couch, not understanding most jokes or being able to relate to most plots, but still enjoying the show as I got to spend time and laugh with them.
我以前放学后和他们在沙发上一边看剧，一边看不懂大部分笑话，也无法对大部分情节产生共鸣，但依然很享受这部剧，因为我能和他们一起度过时光、开怀大笑。
As I got older, I found myself re-watching the show and saw it in such a different way, having had more experiences and knowledge life and relationships.
随着年龄的增长，我发现自己开始重温这部剧，并以一种截然不同的方式看待它，因为我有了更多的人生阅历、生活知识和情感经历。
My family to this day makes fun of me for monopolizing the TV because it plays on a continuous loop in my household most months.
直到今天，我的家人还拿我垄断电视开玩笑，因为这部剧每个月有大部分时间都在我家循环播放。
I'm watching it right now as I am writing this.
我写下这些的时候，正一边看着呢。
Marshall just got slapped by Barney.
马修刚刚被巴尼扇了一巴掌。
Something that has really stuck with me all these years beyond the clever jokes, wise guidance and intricate comedy bits are the music soundtracks played throughout the seasons.
这些年来，除了聪明的笑话、睿智的指导和错综复杂的喜剧桥段之外，真正深深印在我脑海中的，是贯穿各个季节的音乐原声带。
From block party to the shins, band of horses, gold spot, Fort Atlantic and so many more.
从 Block Party 到 The Shins、Band of Horses、Gold Spot、Fort Atlantic 等等。
I've collected the songs into my playlist to listen and grown to favorite them so much.
我把这些歌曲收集到我的播放列表中反复聆听，并深深地爱上了它们。
This past summer I started dating my boyfriend and we immediately bonded over two things.
今年夏天我开始和男友交往，我们立刻因为两件事结下了不解之缘。
Music, concerts, and how I met your mother.
音乐、演唱会，以及《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
Naturally our third date was seeing Josh perform on his tour in Pennsylvania.
自然而然，我们的第三次约会就是去看乔希在宾夕法尼亚州的巡演。
Unbelievable.
难以置信。
It was such a surreal and fun experience hearing him play in person.
现场听他弹奏真是一次超现实且有趣的体验。
And we had the delight of being at one of the special shows where a couple got engaged on the stage.
我们还非常幸运地赶上了一场特别的演出，当时有一对情侣在舞台上求婚。
I think we talked about that on the podcast, right?
我想我们在播客里聊过这个，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
That was a really fun, amazing night.
那真是一个有趣、美妙的夜晚。
Yeah.
对。
Funnily enough, my boyfriend was in New York City with his family just a few weeks later and ran into NPH at a theater.
说来也巧，几周后我男友和家人去纽约市旅游时，居然在一家剧院偶遇了尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯（NPH）。
He immediately called me after his tell me how excited he was at the surprise meet.
他一结束就立刻打电话给我，告诉我他对这次惊喜偶遇有多兴奋。
As our relationship progressed.
随着我们关系的发展。
We've continued to reference him too often.
我们开始太频繁地引用剧中的梗了。
I always eat his olives and watch it together most nights.
我总是吃掉他盘子里的橄榄，而且大多数晚上我们都会一起看剧。
We always dread the Mondays.
我们总是对周一充满恐惧。
I have to drive him to the train station after a weekend together.
度过一个周末后，我不得不开车送他去火车站。
But listening to this podcast on my drive home always cheers me up and gives me something to look forward to every week.
但在回家的路上听这个播客总能让我振作起来，让我每周都有所期待。
Additionally, every time we listen to music together and one of the songs from the show comes on, I quiz him on what episode the song played during.
此外，每当我们在车里一起听音乐，碰巧放中剧里的某一首歌时，我都会考考他这首歌是在哪一集里播出的。
I crush him every time.
我每次都能把他考倒。
Beyond entertainment and guiding my modern love story, himium has continued to teach me countless lessons over the years and reminds me that I still have so much time to find myself in this big world.
除了娱乐和指引我的现代爱情故事外，《老妈》这些年来一直教给我无数的人生道理，并提醒我在这广阔的世界里，我还有大把的时间去寻找自我。
I recently celebrated my 24th birthday and it feels comforting knowing that the characters in season one are 27 and only just beginning to figure out their life goals and plans.
我最近庆祝了24岁生日，得知第一季的角色们当时27岁，才刚刚开始摸索自己的人生目标和计划，这让我感到无比慰藉。
Thank you so much, Craig and Josh, for making my most beloved TV show that has shaped my growing up and continues to be a guide post in my adult life.
非常感谢克雷格和乔希，创造了我最喜爱的电视剧，它塑造了我的成长，并继续成为我成年生活中的指南针。
I continue to eagerly listen to the podcast episodes each Monday, and I am most looking forward to in a few years for you to discuss the controversial finale episode.
我每周一依然会迫不及待地收听播客节目，最期待的莫过于几年后你们讨论那个备受争议的大结局了。
I don't know what she's talking about.
我不知道她在说什么。
And hearing your thoughts on that storyline, personally, I really liked the ending.
并听听你们对那个剧情走向的看法，就我个人而言，我真的很喜欢这个结局。
Thanks, Julia.
谢谢你，茱莉亚。
If you end up reading this on the show, just know there's a girl smiling like crazy listening to this right now in her car.
如果你最后在节目里读到了这封信，请知道现在车里正有一个女孩听着它笑得疯狂呢。
All the best in admiration, Julia.
致以最美好的祝愿和钦佩，茱莉亚。
I love everything about that letter.
我喜欢这封信的一切。
Thank you, Julia.
谢谢你，茱莉亚。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
And I'm so glad we can keep you company on your drive as you part ways from your boyfriend.
我很高兴在我们与男友分开的路上，能用这个节目陪伴你。
But I'm glad you guys have the show to share together.
但我很高兴你们俩有这部剧可以一起分享。
I love when I think it's a great show for couples to watch together.
我喜欢——我认为这是一部非常适合情侣一起看的剧。
I agree.
我同意。
And I also, I love that there's kind of like, there are these, how I met your mother years, 27 to 36, where it's funny when people are in their 20s and they say, I'm 24.
而且我也——我喜欢那种存在着的，类似《老爸老妈浪漫史》年龄段的说法，也就是27岁到36岁，有意思的是当人们二十多岁时会说，我都24岁了。
I'm so old.
我都这么老了。
You know, and you're like, you're like, yeah, your life hasn't started yet.
你知道的，然后你会想，你会觉得，没错，你的人生还没开始呢。
You're not even 27.
你甚至还没到27岁。
So anyway, thanks for that letter, and thanks for all the letters and delighted to spend some time with you all, and we'll see you next time.
总之，谢谢这封信，也谢谢所有的来信，很高兴能和大家度过一段时光，我们下期再见。
Thanks so much.
非常感谢。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们是如何创造老爸老妈的》由乔希·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Audacy 呈现和发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集的执行制片人还有珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matata.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫（Alex Lev）制作和剪辑，我们的联合制片人是道格·马塔塔（Doug Matata）。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯（Alex Reeves）。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，又称 Z 世代大师，是艾米莉·布隆伯格（Emily Blumberg）。
artwork by John Morrow.
封面插图由约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔希·拉德纳创作的《纽约市》，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基（Andrew Majuski）提供了额外的音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪（Lola Kennedy）和埃利奥特·康纳斯（Elliot Connors）。
Visit HowWeMajormother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to to send us an email or a voice message.
访问 HowWeMadeYourMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at joshradner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅乔希·拉德纳的时事通讯，并在 joshradner.com 上查看他的音乐以及其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas's debut novel.
订购克雷格·托马斯的首部小说。
That's not how it happened, wherever books are sold.
事情并不是这样的，各大图书销售平台均有售。
And check out his other published writings at CraigThomasRider.com.
您也可以在 CraigThomasRider.com 网站上查看他的其他出版作品。
And you can subscribe to my own dead father's society, also on Substack.
您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我已故父亲的社群。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解更多关于如何贡献力量的信息，本节目目前正在开展为先天性小儿心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，它会跳舞。